last video we saw what happens when we
have resistors in series now let's see
what happens when we have resistors in
parallel all right let me pick a new
color new color will be magenta
there's my battery positive negative
there is my ideal conducting wire here's
my ideal conducting wire but then and
this is new it branches off and I have
two resistances I have one here that was
my printer making a random noise if you
heard that I call them printer burps and
that's another resistance and let's say
that this is this has a resistance r1
this has a resistance r2 and of course
the non-intuitive convention is that the
current flows from the positive to the
negative terminal but we know that the
electrons are actually flowing in the
other direction
and I want to keep saying that because I
don't know I think it's so important to
just to understand what's actually
happening as opposed to the convention
well anyway in the previous video we
said well when we have when we have
devices or components in series that the
current through the entire circuit is
constant but let's think about what
happens here let's think about what
happens here so we have these electrons
let's think about it from the electron
flow the electrons are flowing flowing
flowing at a given rate right and then
here they have a choice right some of
them can take this top path some of them
can take this bottom path right so if
you think about it the flow of electrons
in this branch plus the flow of
electrons in that branch have to add up
to the flow of the electrons in this
branch right and then they're going to
meet back up and then the flow of
electrons here so if we if we think of
it this way and now I'm going to go back
to the convention that this is I 1 so
you have these electrons flowing at a
given rate right this is the current
right here they're going to branch off
and you know maybe half of them go if
the resistances we'll see if the
resistances are equal if these are kind
of very you know both of these branches
that have have an equal amount of
capacity in terms of how fast the
electrons can flow through if they're
equal or since we're going to card in
this direction let's talk about
positrons or I don't know you know
positive charges if the positive charges
although as I just want to keep saying
that is not the positive charges they're
moving as the electrons but if we say
that the lack lack of electrons can flow
equally easily between boat paths that's
if the resistances were the same we
could imagine that the current the flow
would split itself up and then over here
would meet back up and then we would say
that the current here would also be i1
but let's figure out what the currents
going let's call this current i2 i2 and
let's call this current i3 so I think it
is reasonable and you could imagine with
water pipes or anything that the current
going into the branch is equal to the
current exiting the branch or you could
even think of it that the current
entering when the when the current i2
and i1 merge that they combine and they
they become current one right I mean to
think about it in a given second if this
is five coulombs per second I'm just
making up numbers and this is six
coulombs per second six six I can't
write properly six coulombs per second
right in a given second right here
you're going to have five coulombs per
set five coulombs coming from this
branch and 6 coulombs coming from this
branch so you're going to have eleven
coulombs per second coming out once
they've merged so this would be 11
coulombs per second so I think hopefully
that makes sense to you that they that
that this current is equal to the
combination of this current and that
current now what do we also know we also
know that the voltage along this entire
ideal across ascent entire ideal wire is
constant so the then voltage let me draw
that let me do it in another color in
blue so for example the voltage anywhere
along this blue that I'm filling in is
going to be the same because this wire
is an ideal conductor and you can almost
view this blue part as an extension of
the positive terminal of the battery and
very similarly
the LME see do it in yellow we could
draw this wire as an extension of the
negative terminal of the battery this is
an extension of the negative terminal of
the battery right so the voltage
difference between here and here so
let's call that the total voltage or
let's just say that this is called at
the voltage write the voltage drift
between between that point and that
point is the exact same thing as the
voltage difference between this point
and this point which is the exact same
thing as a voltage difference between
this point and this point right so what
can we can say so what is what is the
total current in the system if we just
view this as a black box that this is
some type of total resistance right well
it would be the total current in the
system would be the total voltage the
voltage divided by let's call this our
total resistance right let's say we
couldn't see this and we just said oh
that's just some total resistance right
and that is equal to the current going
through r1 this is is this yeah this is
i1 this is one right here this is
current i1 well what's current i1 what's
going to be the voltage across this
resistor divided by the resistance right
that's what Ohm's law tells us V is
equal to IR or another way we could say
it is V over R is equal to I right so i1
is equal to the voltage across this
resistor well we just said that voltage
is the same thing as this voltage right
the voltage here is the same thing as a
voltage here the voltage here is the
same thing as voltage here so this the
voltage across that resistor is still V
and so the current flowing across that
resistor is V over R one and the same
logic what that what is i2 i2 is this
current what is the voltage across this
device well that's just V again right
it's the same thing as a voltage across
this device so it's V over r2 by Ohm's
law well all these V's are the same so
we can divide both sides of that
equation by V and we get 1 over the
total resistance
is equal to 1 over r1 plus 1 over r2 and
you could make that argument if there
was you know if we had an r3 here let's
say that you know we had another device
and then it was there and as r3 we just
you know you could use the exact same
argument you would have a plus one over
r3 and if you had RN or you know 10 of
them you just keep that one over R 4 R 5
etc so let's see if we can use this
information we've learned to actually
solve a problem and I actually find it
it's always easy to solve a problem than
to explain the theory behind a problem
you'll see that most of these circuit
problems it's actually very basic
mathematics so let's say I have a 16
volt battery plus minus it's 16 volts
and let's say and just to hit the point
home that you always don't have to draw
circuits the same although it is nice if
you're actually drawing complicated
circuits I could draw it like this
I can draw the circuit like this and
let's say that there's a resistor here
and then let's say there's a wire and
then there's another resistor here and
that this decides to do some random
loopy thing here and that they connect
here and that they come back here this
strange thing that I have drawn which
you will never see in any textbook
because most people are more reasonable
than me is the exact same you can almost
view it topologically if the the exact
same circuit as what I drew in the
previous diagram although now I will
assign numbers to it let's say that this
resistance is 20 ohms 20 ohms and let's
say that this resistance is 5 ohms what
I want to know is what is the current
through the system so or you know first
left to figure out what the equivalent
resistance is and then we could just use
Ohm's law to figure out the current
system so we want to know what the
current is and we know that the
convention is the current flows from the
positive terminal to the negative
terminal so how do we figure out the
equivalent resistance well we know that
we just hopefully prove to you that the
total resistance is equal to 1 over this
resistor plus 1 over this resistor
so one over is I won't keep right is
equal what's 1 over 20 well actually
let's just make a fraction so it's 1
over 20 plus 1 over 5 is 1 over 20
that's for over 20 right so 1 over our
total resistance is equal to 5 over 20
which is equal to what 1 over 4 right 5
over 20 so if 1 over r is equal to 1
over 4 r must be equal to 4 so R is
equal to 4 ohms so we could redraw this
crazy circuit as this I'll try to draw
it small down here we could redraw this
where this resistance is 4 ohms and this
is 16 volts right we could say that this
is this whole thing combined is really
just a resistor that is 4 ohms well if
we have a 16 volt potential difference
current is flowing that way even though
that's not the electrons are doing and
that's what our resistance is 4 ohms
what is the current V equals IR Ohm's
law the voltage is 16 volts it equals
the current times 4 ohms
current so current is equal to 16
divided by 4 is equal to 4 amps so let's
do something interesting let's figure
out what the current is flowing through
what's this what's the current i1 and
what's this current i2 well we know that
the potential difference from here to
here is also 16 volts right because this
whole thing is is as it is is
essentially the same potential and this
whole thing is essentially the same
potential so you have 16 volts across
there 16 volts divided by 20 ohms so
let's call this I 1 so i1 is equal to 16
volts divided by 20 ohms which is equal
to what 4/5 so it equals 4/5 of an
ampere or 0.8 amperes right and
similarly what is the amount of current
flowing through here
I - I'm due this is a different color
it's getting confusing I'll do it in the
vibrant yellow so the current falling
through here once again the potential
difference from here that's not
different enough the potential
difference from here to here is also 16
volts right so the current is going to
be i2 is going to be equal to 16 over 5
which is equal to 3 and 1/5 amps so most
of the current is actually flowing
through this and that makes sense
because the resistance is less right so
that should hopefully give you a little
bit of intuition of what's going on and
less current is flowing through here
so i1 through the 20 ohm resistor is we
can say 0.8 amps it's I 1 and I 2
through the 5 ohm resistor is equal to 3
point 2 amps and it makes sense that
when you add these two currents together
the current the 3.2 ampere is flowing
through here and the point 8 ampere is
flowing through here that when they
merge they merge and then you have 4
amperes flowing through there anyway
hopefully I have given you some
intuition on what happens when we put
parallel when we put resistors in
parallel I will see you in the next
video